Uh, I'll sing those first on your lyric sheet
says four lines there.
Um, I'll do those twice
and then actually I'm gonna walk us through it.
Uh, so the second time through will be,
I'm calling on the God
a shepherd Boy.
Courageous. I may not
face, but I've gotten my own.
Oh God, my God. I need you. Oh God. So
Just give a little space there, um, afterwards.
Um, and then once we get to Sothebys,
down chorus twice through there.
And then, uh, we'll just go to
that instrumental before the bridges.
And then from that point on, the rest
of the song is exactly the same, like the recording un up
until there was a six minute mark on the recording.
But, um, basically it gets us into doing that chorus twice
and instrumentals, um, out.
Where do you want us to come in with you?
Uh, I think it would be good to come in
after the Bridges are going.
Um, I'm, I'm gonna do my best to try to get them to,
they know the song, so I'm gonna get 'em to sing it.
Um, so I might back off a little bit.
So I think the should start coming in on, uh,
maybe after the instrumental, just
so it leaves a lot of space there.
Is that cool? After the instrumental
after the chorus is twice before the Bridges correct.
Don't want guide? No, it's just an intro guy
Who's the Guy Intro.
Yeah. Yeah. Do you want the count?
It'll help. Yeah.
If you don't want the guy wanna count,
It won't, I don't think it'll matter.
Yeah. Uh,
so
we are That's correct.
Um, yeah,
so the instrumental is four times.
We're not going to bridge four. Just know that coming.
Oh, we will kind of come back out of that.
I will probably do another chorus there.
Yeah. You freed your, freed the captives then part. Yeah.
And we'll be back down.
Um, I think it'd be really helpful to get to
that progression.
Uh, bridge
of it was like the Lord.
So we're ringing out,
Uh, Uh, let's give this a try.
I know there's a lot here. Uh, we got this.
We'll work through some kinks
as along the way if we need to.
What's
So we're playing through this as Lord supper's being passed,
taking all those things.
So we'll be in this intro for a while.
It'll be easy just to jump in when we need to
Of God
it
All
You,
you deserve the
Inc.
All
You
a shepherd boy
I calling on
Not, but I've got
my giant.
Oh God. My God. I need, oh God.
God, I need you.
How I need you.
I'm standing on your faith.
On your faith.
God, I need you. God.
I need you now. I need
you.
Hear your children. You hear your children.
You,
you prayers by
You.
Now you
God.
You wanna,
God I need you
on
God.
God, God.
I, I need,
oh my God, I
Need you.
Oh God. My God. I need you now.
Oh, I need you now.
Or of ages.
I'm standing on your faithfulness
on your faith.
Say, let's stay on the wand there. Yeah.
You went to the what?
I went To the
Oh you did. Okay.
Sorry.
I missed, I I'm had of trouble hearing the one over three.
That was it, where it started.
I think it would be Okay. One over three.
You are the one you king
Lord over everything.
Jesus. There is no other Jesus.
There is no other will never change.
Your name is here to Jesus.
There is there?
Yeah. That's great. Yeah.
Cool. Uh, any thoughts throughout that?
Yes.
Yeah. Yeah.
I would say vocal is coming in as much as you want
to on these songs for sure.
Um, there's a little bit of a pace on
that verse four on saying, God,
that might feel a little weird with everybody in,
but I think we could, everything else let's sing.
That's good.
Yep. Yeah. As
we were going through that, I have a little bit of a plan
to prompt them to do something and not just listen to us.
I do have an idea though, like an intentional idea.
So, but no good.
I I definitely don't want the moment
of just them standing there watching those instruments.
We so Yeah. Yeah. I'm gonna try to keep them there.
That's good. Okay.
Ah, please do. Um, do we wanna run it again?
Uh, structurally I felt it felt pretty comfortable that run
through, but do we want to run anything again through that?
Yeah.
Cool. Yeah, we can do that.
So, who's like the Lord we're gonna do?
Who is like the Lord? Um, just to get some there.
Yep.
Uh, verse four. So I'm
calling on the God of Jake David, sorry.
Who made us shepherd boy courageous.
I'm gonna sing that two times
and then I may not face Goliath, but I've got my own giants.
Small little pause chorus twice right there. Yep.
And then bridge one, bridge two.
Bridge three holds back into chorus twice.
Yep.
Then it is, uh, well this, yeah,
we do some instrumentals there twice through.
And then, uh, then we'll be in lose like the Lord. Bridge
The darkest
who can break the curse generations.
Oh,
you the one Lord over everything.
Jesus. There is no, Jesus There is
name, names you to say,
I will say quick.
All right. Anything else that we need to cover?
Hi. Got Uhhuh.
Mm-hmm. Yep. Yep.
Let's, let's do that offline.
Let's do that. We'll do that.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Uh, vocals.
It's got it over here and we'll, we can walk through that.
Yeah.
Uh, let's work on first.
See you
never I've got I
The people and people.
So her and I should be on the
Yes.
You're
I see you.
That's perfect.
Never I've,
Uh, let's do the, do
that second time period.
Bridge one and two.
You. I witness it
and I'm confident I see
you and confident.
I'll see
you feel,
and
I was struggling.
That's we'll just swap on that one. Okay. Last.
It's a weird heart.
Which one? The one that's
See again.
Yeah. Let's
you love you.
You,
I
Cataracts don't where you at?
Yeah. As long as we're the
same, but all
How we doing?
Um, on
Let's begin by.
Can you
mere, mere
thi
12 for a long time?
Its gotta remember
those days.
So he gives us,
lets us know that the
says reminds
we limitations.
Why are you pass
Christian?
There are people
already alone
or their
show
for everybody gets
Dad, mom,
cool.
Record.
Re
all the bumper video.
Alright, cool. Uh,
we'll start five.
Oh, uh, let's,
I guess this is trial and error.
Welcome to Henderson Hills.
We are disciple makers anchored in truth, compelled by love
and desperately dependent on the Lord.
We are generous with what God has given us
and we share life giving help with those around us.
Our mission is to equip one another to love Jesus.
And lip syn, we are glad you're here,
Are new here. And this
is one of your first times visiting with us.
Uh, first of all, I wanna say welcome
and I'm glad that you are here.
Um, one thing that I wanna make sure that you, um,
don't leave here without doing is at least getting
to shake someone's hand and meet someone here.
And a very easy way to do that is to go to our new here, uh,
desk out at the lobby and meet someone out there.
They'll be able to give you a little bit more information
about who we are here at Henderson Hills.
And if you have been coming here for some time,
maybe you've been visiting for the last few weeks or months,
and you're ready to take that next step
of diving a little bit deeper into community within this
church, we have a meaningful, uh, membership class
that is starting next week.
Uh, so if you'll, is it next week? I think it's next week.
That's right. Yeah.
Next week from 12 to two in the green room.
We'd love for you to come be a part of that as well.
So, uh, go ahead and dive into that and,
and learn more about who we are at Henderson Hills with
that meaningful work membership workshop.
And then finally, if you are looking for a place
to serve here, and maybe you are a singer
or you play an instrument,
or you wanna learn how to be involved with running sound
or lights or cameras.
Here we are having a worship ministry interest lunch next
week as well, uh,
at noon in the conference room, in the offices.
Uh, so come to that as well
and get a little bit of information about what it means
to serve in the worship ministry here at Henderson Hills.
To do that, you can meet with some
of our staff members out in the lobby after the service
and we'd love to give you some more information there.
And then finally, uh, I would love to invite all of us
to stand up and take some time to greet one another.
Uh, get to know each other a little bit more.
Um, come up with an icebreaker,
Someone Chest bumps in here.
We're doing something right. All right,
well, let me invite you to make your way back to your seats
and let's get involved in some time of worship this morning.
We're gonna start this morning singing a new song,
the wave it song here this morning,
and to put ourselves in the right frame of reference, uh,
for what we're singing in this song.
I'd like to read from Psalm one 13 this morning.
This is starting in verse five of Psalm one 13.
He says, who is like the Lord our God who is seated on high,
who looks far down on the heavens
and the earth, he raises the poor from the dust
and lifts the needy from the Ashe to make them sit
with princes, with the princes of his people.
He gives the barren woman a home,
making her the joyous mother of children.
Praise the Lord.
And that's what I want us to do this morning
as we reflect on who our God is, who Jesus is.
And just ask that question, who is like the Lord?
And as we, as we consider that, let's respond
and praise this morning as we sing this song.
So let's worship together this morning
There before
the stars and sun who
said,
who can make the darkest demon?
Who can
the,
the Lord, everything.
Jesus. There is no, Jesus there is
Your name.
A
When I was lost,
your presence was where I found home.
You
in every and you
never without.
I,
I
You good and have witnessed it.
You are strong and have witnessed it. Your content.
I witnessed it
and I'm confident I'll see it again.
And,
And
I,
I
Faithful seen you breathe
worthy.
Pour my praise. You're worthy.
God, you're worthy of all of it.
God, we thank you that you are worthy.
God, we thank you for all the things
that you've done in our lives.
God, may we be quick to proclaim those things.
In your name we pray. Amen. You may be seated.
That's it. Okay.
Didn't feel like that was finished. Okay. Yeah.
The court progression didn't finished. It was not Yeah.
May tweak that for next week.
'cause that's gonna make people like you.
Like don't feel right. Resolve please.
Um, okay.
So I'm gonna preach for a while about David
and the last point about him
and Jesus fulfilling what David couldn't.
And then talk about
Jesus specifically.
A couple things at the very end.
Then I will pray, leave some prayer time there
and then say, invite Chris back up to do the Lord's supper.
So let's have Chris come.
So we're going to enter a time of, um,
participating in the Lord's Supper
and I'll explain a little bit of what that is.
Um, and I'll also explain that, um, if you are not yet a,
uh, disciple of Jesus, uh, believer, follower of Jesus, um,
we'd invite you just to, um, let those trays pass by you.
This is something that Jesus commanded believers to do,
his disciples to do.
So it been that time reflecting.
But if you take those elements, um,
explain a little bit about how we're going to take those,
spend some time in reflection, also inviting those
that are serving to go ahead and start passing those out.
Give a little bit of time for that to, to be passed.
Then I will, um, read from one Corinthians 11
and we'll take the elements together.
Um, and do we need
a prayer moment you think after that?
Or just go straight into the song?
Yeah. After we take,
yeah.
Okay. I'll do that. I'll pray
and then we'll set up the next one.
And All the saints and
God
Of
for from you,
you deserve glory.
David incense rise
Incense,
Inc.
You.
I'm calling all the God of David
Who Made a shepherd boy courage.
I'm Calling all God
who made a shepherd.
Boy,
I may not face Goliath,
But I've got my own giant
God.
My God I need you.
God, I need you.
I need you.
I call core rock of ages.
I'm standing on your faithfulness.
On your faithfulness.
Oh God. God, I need,
oh God, my God.
I need you. Need you
of I'm standing on
you.
Your children. That you hear your children.
Now you're the saying God,
you're the saying God, you
answered prayers back then
and you, you're
the God.
You God,
You're Providing,
You're providing
God.
I,
oh
My God, I need you.
Oh God, my God. I need you now.
How? I need you now.
Rock, rock of ages.
I'm standing on your faithfulness
on your,
you are the one true king
Lord over everything.
Jesus. There is no one Jesus.
There is no other.
Your word will never change.
And your name is here to stay. Jesus.
There is no other Jesus.
There is no other.
The mighty light of the pure and,
and great.
I'm the God who saves the nations
the one we bow before.
So let every voice sing out who is like,
who is like
The Lord.
Who is like the,
So we'll end it with, um, call
to pray down here at the front.
And that'll be it. Can we
do the bumper video again
and see if there's a way we can ease the transition of
that a little bit?
What do you think? Just fade the music out
completely before it gets to that.
Or the bumper video, the way it ends,
it just ends on such an awkward, like,
and it said like a minor chord and it starts to go up
And it, and then I'll have nick extend it
To resolve it. Yeah.
Yeah. It it leaves a tension. Yeah.
There's a tension to leave it there.
My Strain.
Let that
never needs to
the Lord
King Mountains
and Wilke the song
of your day, my joy
of your
to the promise I have in you.
My
Savior Is not like you
all of my days.
I wanna praise the wonders of your right
Love. Oh,
You are my, our
huge and strain.
Let every I'm
To the Lord.
Let us say, are I just
to the King Mountain
ever? Not
The song
Day for joy.
I'm the of your
I love you forever. Nothing
Comes To the promise heart.
And you
I was alone.
But now where I belong,
I and I
want turn around.
I
I Know I don't ever go back
When You,
I
could
Ever Wanna be a slave again
and left my James broke.
And world could never
change because now I'm saved.
Your love won't turn
Around.
I'm Settling down here.
I
Don't, I don't ever want
I been down.
I close that door.
You're never Go searching
because I
land.
I Know. I don't ever wanna go back.
I been down. I
When fear,
no fear in this is the
power of Christ.
And from life's first cry
to final Jesus commands my
no power
from he returns
or calls me the power
of Christ
here in the power Christ.
When I think of the and the bad
and the ugly, you love me.
No matter how far I fall,
when I find that I'm down
and I feel like I'm down me, you surround me.
You threw it off.
Never be day. I get
My,
My my God.
Not Know you are party.
Hurry, hurry
God my worthy.
You are worthy. So worthy.
You, worthy of it.
There's a love that I found that is uncondition.
You supply me a peppering. I need,
He My God is bigger than the world
is stronger than the one try to come against
Me.
You want everything.
So I missing your money.
You want want, you're so holy
God worthy.
You are worthy you
worthy, you are worthy.
Doti shine. You've always been
Patient.
You worth big happy.
So I give you
My whole heart. I
Surrender my life.
Life and call you my God.
You hardly you are
get you soul.
Get you my God.
Come worthy.
You are so worthy.
Be your always birthday for you
and all you and on you
to
This is where I, right inside,
this is where I
I
that again, this is where I
right inside your house,
this is where I
Be Right inside.
If I was a bird, I,
I
don't ever fight.
I know I along. I
right your side.
I know where I belong.
Right here by your side to open fields.
And I know that you are eating me.
I don't want,
I don't
of I.
Amen. Those who the of.
Can we say it again?
God, can I,
can I say it again?
Come on.
Manwell. In the of God, can I name
Me Happy in the house of God?
Can we save?
Oh, You name me
Happy.
The
David said, I rather have one day in your house
than a thousand anywhere else.
David said,
I'd rather have one day in your house
than a thousand anywhere else.
So my soul says,
I'd rather have one day in your house than,
than I'd rather have one.
I'd rather have one day
than thousand
Else.
Those who dwell in the house of God.
Wow.
Wow. It Makes my so
Glad.
I'd rather hold. I'd rather
Be Anywhere for anywhere.
Rather, I'd rather sweep
The,
the,
the valley of the I will feel.
No, we no, we walk
through the valley of the I will feel
no, we no we
tree
through the family.
No way. Look big.
No, we no let,
no, no,
no more remain.
No my side.
You the Miami,
my side on
the Miami.
How much is it?
Welcome to Henderson Hills.
We are disciple makers, anchored in truth, compelled by love
and desperately dependent on the Lord.
We are generous with what God has given us
and we share life giving hope with those around us.
Our mission is to equip one another to love Jesus.
And lip syn. We're glad you're here.
Good morning church. We are so glad
that you are here this morning.
Um, a few are new to Henderson Hills
as you're making your way in, uh,
maybe it's the first time you're here
or maybe you've been here for a couple weeks
and you haven't had a chance to
really get plugged in anywhere.
What I would like to first off is just invite you to, uh,
well one thing, just meet someone in here.
Uh, we'll have a second to turn around
and greet each other in a second.
So make sure that you don't leave today
before someone is, uh, shaking your hand.
At least introduce themselves to you.
But another really easy way to start to that, that,
that process of getting plugged in here is to go, uh,
meet someone at our new here desk out in the lobby
afterwards, and they can get you some more information about
what it means to join in, in the life
of Henderson Hills here.
For those of you that maybe have been here for a little bit
of time, maybe a couple weeks
or have been coming for a couple of months,
and you're ready to take that next step of diving deeper
into the life of Henderson Hills,
we have a meaningful membership class that is next Sunday.
Uh, would love to invite you all to come be a part of that.
If you have not, uh, gone through that before,
or if you're just interested in what it looks like
to be a member of Henderson Hills, we'd love to invite you
to come join that as well.
And then the third thing I wanna announce this morning is if
you are looking for a place
to serve here at Henderson Hills, uh, maybe you are a singer
or maybe you play an instrument
or perhaps you're interested in learning how
to run the audio and the visual and the, the lights
and cameras and all that we have here.
Uh, we have an interest worship ministry,
interest lunch next week as well.
That'll be at noon in the offices.
Uh, just come to that, uh, be able to ask some questions,
see what it's like to serve along in the
worship ministry here.
We'd love to be for you to be a part of that.
We'll also have some staff members out in the lobby
after the services if you want to ask 'em a few questions
to see what that looks like.
I would love you to be a, a part of
what we do here at the worship ministry as well.
And like I alluded to, I want to spend this time making sure
that we greet one another, uh,
that we spend the time being a little bit more, more
of the fellowship of the community of Henderson Hills here.
So I want you all to stand up.
Take a little bit of time to greet those around you.
Maybe ask them if we should have a banjo
or a harmonica as part of our worship ministry next.
All right. I, man, I hate to end the conversations early.
Hopefully we can pick those back up after service.
But as we make our way back to our seats this morning,
we're gonna get involved in our time of worship and singing.
This morning. We're gonna be, uh, singing a newer song
that we haven't sung here this morning.
And to explain a little bit what we're singing.
What I would, what I want to do is I wanna start
with reading, uh, Psalm one 13.
Uh, I'm gonna start in verse four
and just listen to this and consider this.
'cause this will set up everything that we're about
to sing together as a church.
So Psalm one 13, starting in verse four, the Lord is high
above all nations in his glory above the heavens.
Who is like the Lord our God who is seated on high,
who looks far down on the heavens and the earth.
He raises the poor from the dust
and he lifts the needy from the ash heap to make them sit
with princes, with the princes of his people.
He gives the barren woman a home,
making her the joyous mother of children.
Praise the Lord.
And so this song that we're going to sing together, it asks
that question, who is like the Lord
who can do these things that the Lord does?
And as we consider that this morning,
let's result in the same way that, that that Psalm does.
And just praising the Lord, declaring how great he is.
So let's sing that together this morning
and declare how great our God is
was there before there was
who illuminates the stars And Son,
who has said,
And who Can
The Storm whisper,
who can make the dark run?
Who can
the one, the Lord over everything
Jesus.
No, Jesus, there is no Father.
Your world will never
Change because
Your name is here to say no.
No.
The Lord
King Jesus. There's
no one like him. Amen.
When I was lost all alone,
your presence was where I found home.
You were there now,
every without
right now sing.
I've witnessed it.
I
God's given us each a story to declare who he is.
So let's sing out of all the good things
that he's done in our lives that we can tell others about.
Good. You are good. And I've witnessed it.
You are strong and I've witnessed it.
You are constant. I've witnessed it
and I'm confident I'll see it again
and again, you,
and I'm confident
your promise is
Never.
And I've got
God, we thank you that you are worthy of all
of our praise, all of our worship.
God, wait, may we think about the things
that you have done in our lives and share that with others.
God, I thank you for salvation
and the good news that that brings us.
Thank you so much. You may have a seat.
Hello. Good morning Church.
Isn't it great to be able to gather like this?
Uh, my name's John. If I haven't met you yet.
I'm one of the pastors here.
I get to preach most of the time.
But I would love to meet you if I get a chance
to at some point soon.
Uh, today is a really exciting day
because we are kicking off a new sermon series
that will take us until Thanksgiving, last fall and spring.
We studied the book of First Samuel looking at that
as it got us into the story.
We're gonna continue the story.
Now as we study the book of Second Samuel last week,
Aaron reminded us really well
that basically this whole thing, first
and second Samuel has been about God's peoples abandonment
of God as their king.
And it was supposed to be a theocracy.
And they were instead searching
for an earthly king like everyone else around them.
But as they did, so a further question was
who was gonna be that king?
That was part of the process of developing
what we saw in one Samuel.
That God had promised a certain man to lead the nation
as the king, but who was that going to be?
And so we looked at who will reign? Who shall reign.
We used this chart, if you remember, we tracked
how God was going to bring that about,
how the transition from judges to kings happened.
And then how the first king was Saul.
And, and Saul looked the part head
and shoulders above everyone else was handsome.
All of this, he looked like he would be the one God would've
picked, but his heart was not close to God.
And so God had promised a man
after God's own heart to lead his people.
And so God anointed David to replace Saul.
Well, second Samuel is the story
of David's rise to the throne.
How did he come into that position?
But then also, how did he, how did he handle it
as he stepped into that role?
Now we're gonna use another chart here in Second Samuel.
So you'll see this every week.
You might take a picture of it at some point, either today
or in the next few weeks.
But as you look at this chart, you're gonna see
David's rise and fall.
That's the book of two Samuel. Shows us that.
And we will learn yes, that, that David
was God's promise king for Israel,
in fact was Israel's greatest king.
But we'll also see that David was limited.
There were some serious limitations.
There's there's a rise to the throne. Yes.
But then we're also gonna see David's faults along the way
and the consequences of what comes as a result.
He's not always the hero we make him out to be,
which means there's something important we need
to just set up from the beginning here.
David is merely a pointer to the true king.
We'll see a lot about David. He's the, the example.
But he's merely a pointer to the true promised
king Jesus.
And so in one sense, we'll see two
Samuel's David's testimony.
Like it's his successes, it's his failures,
it's his experience of God's grace and mercy in his life.
But also, we'll see how all of that points us
forward to the Messiah.
So as we get into this, I wanna start us off just
by praying, uh, briefly and,
and getting this, this whole series laid before the Lord,
because it's not my word.
It's, it's not anything that we can do.
It's, it's his word to us.
And so let's ask for God's power really on this
as we go through the next months.
God thank you. Thank you for your word.
Thank you for the opportunity to study your word,
that we get to see it
and we pray Holy Spirit, that you would apply it
to our lives knowing it happened
a couple thousand years ago.
But the relevance of it for us today
help us to see through the lenses you want us to see
that our world is not that much different.
Our lives, our hearts are not much
that much different from what they were then.
But we need your power. God. This is yours Earth.
Get us outta the way. All the distractions
to let us see your word and see what you want us to see and
and apply what you want us to see.
Not merely being hearers but doers of your word.
Help us God in Jesus' name. Amen.
So I invite you now to turn
to two Samuel in the Old Testament.
It's pretty early in there.
If you start flipping from the front, you'll find it there.
Put a bookmark there. Of course we're gonna be in
that every week over the course of this narrative.
Now as you find it, it might seem like as we go
through this, that we're taking really big chunks
of scripture a couple chapters at a time.
But that's the nature of narrative.
Like you can't break up narrative at times without
losing the point of the story.
So you can look at a little section,
but then you miss the bigger picture.
And so we're gonna take some bigger chunks of it.
Like today we're gonna look at chapters one
through three of two Samuel.
'cause part of it recaps the end of one Samuel,
which we already kind of know about.
But then it also sets up David's reign as the king.
And so we're gonna see all this point together
to see David as the king.
That God wanted, the kind of king that God wanted,
that he was not one who was gonna seize power through
violence or manipulation.
He was going to have an an evident
integrity in the way he was leading.
It's gonna show us all that here in these couple chapters
about David because we're gonna watch him respond
to Saul's death.
Saul died at the end of First Samuel.
We're gonna watch him respond to that.
But then we're also gonna watch him lead through people
in crisis, in chaos and division.
How did he handle that? And we'll see how again, all
of it points us to the greater king Jesus.
And so look with me now at Second Samuel chapter one.
I'm not gonna be able to read all
of these chapters 'cause our time's limited.
But I wanna give you highlights, some summary statements.
We'll dig into the parts that are most critical.
But, but here's what happens right outta the gate.
This is the parallel account to what we saw at the end
of one Samuel of Saul's death.
This is what David was experiencing
as Saul was experiencing the end of his life.
And so let me just again set the tone.
There was, there was a big battle with the Philistines,
a lot of people coming against Israel and,
and David was in a different part of the country.
And so he was experiencing this and hearing this.
But then Saul and Jonathan,
and that's David's best friend, they were in this battle.
And then David heard in this scene about Saul
and Jonathan having died in the battle.
How did he hear about this? Well, they didn't have
like Snapchat or anything.
It wasn't anything like that. It was, it was this man
running a long way to tell David he happened
to be from Saul's camp and he happened to be in Amalekite.
The Amalekites were the defeated enemies of God's people
and they were enslaved by the the leaders.
And so this man came and told David about Saul's death.
Now he wanted to impress David.
David didn't know who he was. He wanted to impress David.
And he in his mind thought, man, David's gonna love
to hear about his enemy, Saul dying.
And so I'm gonna tell him I'm gonna be the one
to inform David about Saul's death.
And what he does in it is he says, Hey, hey David.
I was the one who killed Saul. It was me.
Now if you remember from one Samuel 31, that's a discrepancy
because Saul in the battle was so badly wounded,
he actually fell on his own sword in that chapter.
And so we discover that this amalekite was apparently lying
to David to gain favor.
Maybe I'll get a a part in his, his kingship.
I'll get a a good role.
Well let's watch David respond to the news.
This is verses 11 and 12 of two Samuel one.
He hears of Saul's death.
Then David took hold of his clothes and tore them.
And so did all the men who were with him.
And they mourned and wept and fasted until evening for Saul
and for Jonathan, his son, and for the people of the Lord
and for the house of Israel
because they had fallen by the sword.
Now don't forget something here.
Saul was the man who had tried to kill David multiple times.
He'd hunted him like a wild animal.
He had David on the run for 10 years in the wilderness.
That was who David, look at his heart, right David, instead
of hating Saul, there was grief.
Instead of rejoicing over Saul's death,
there was a sense of mourning.
David grieved the loss of the Lord's anointed king.
Even though it was Saul, David grieved it
because he was anointed by God.
He even wrote a song. David wrote most of the Psalms.
He even wrote a song of lament
to be sung by God's people.
You find it here in verses 19 through 27.
I'm just gonna read a couple key parts of this.
This is David's song about Saul and Jonathan dying.
It says, your glory, Israel is slain on your high places.
How the mighty have fallen.
Saul and Jonathan, beloved
and lovely in life, in death, they were not divided.
They were swifter than eagles.
They were stronger than lions.
How the mighty have fallen the weapons of war perished.
So David is grieving even publicly
about Saul's death.
Not only that, but look at how he responded
to the Amalekite man who told him about Saul's death
and told him that he had been the one who killed Saul.
Look at verses 14 through 16.
David said to him, how is it that you are not afraid
to put out your hand to destroy the Lord's anointed?
Then David called one of the young men
and said, go execute him.
And he struck him down so that he died.
And David said to him, your blood be on your head
for your own mouth has testified against you saying,
I have killed the Lord's anointed.
And so David had this man who claimed to kill Saul,
had him executed because of his admission.
Like this man should have recognized the sanctity
of the Lord's anointed king As Saul was the king.
And he should not have have been
so flippantly handling that life.
David himself, remember how David handled this?
David had a couple opportunities
to take Saul's life, but he didn't.
He Could have gained the throne improperly
by taking Saul's life, but he didn't.
This man, the Amalekite man was trying to manipulate things
to his own ends.
And what happened? He paid the price.
Here's the point. David revealed his
heart in his response to Saul's death.
Like we see very clearly David's heart
when he hears about Saul's death.
This man who tried to take him out, he's gone.
How did David respond? Well, he could have rejoiced.
Saul's finally gone.
The pathway's finally clear for me to be the king.
He could have rejoiced thrown a party, but he didn't.
He grieved. He mourned, he wept.
Which leads to a question for us.
Is that how you love your enemies?
Like do you grieve when your enemy suffers?
When your enemy, your opponent, the antagonist in your life,
do you grieve when they suffer or especially when they die?
Or are you more apt to throw a party for it?
Are you to celebrate it?
Like to, to encourage the excitement around you about
that person's downfall?
We saw this in Romans 12 this summer.
One of the most challenging realignment statements in Romans
12 is verses 19 and 20.
It says, beloved never avenge yourselves,
but leave it to the wrath of God.
For it is written, vengeance is mine,
I will repay, says the Lord.
To the contrary, if your enemy is hungry, feed him.
If he's thirsty, give him something to drink for.
By so doing, you will heap burning coals on his head.
Remember, David had multiple opportunities
to take out his enemy to kill Saul, but he didn't.
He could have made his life a whole lot easier,
but instead he trusted that God's justice is perfect.
Our revenge is never perfect.
We don't always see the whole story.
We don't always handle it exactly as we should.
And so he trusted God to take care of Saul as he did.
And notice it turned out a whole lot better
for David than if he would've done it himself
because David is is completely innocent.
There's no way anyone could accuse David
of anything improper here he was in a
completely different part of the country.
Didn't even know it was happening.
He's his hands were clean in Saul's death.
How could he say that?
Because he had overcome evil with good,
he didn't try to overcome evil with more evil, right?
Martin Luther King Jr. Said that that only adds to evil.
He said, I'm gonna overcome evil with good.
And it turned out exactly right for David.
And so this principle from Romans 12
is the same for us today.
For us who are believers in Christ, follow Jesus.
We claim to be Christians in our lives.
That means things should look different in, in our lives.
Things should be different in how we handle those
who oppose us, those who are enemies,
whatever we would call it, right?
Things should look a little bit different in
how we handle things like the way we speak about those
who are on the opposite side of the spectrum from us.
Our social media usage should be different in the way we
speak about people who may be different or may be opposed.
The bumper stickers on your car should look different
than everybody else's in the world.
This is true about us.
Now it doesn't mean you, you would trust your enemy.
I I get that. But if Jesus said, love your enemies
and pray for those who persecute you,
then we should not participate in rejoicing over
our opponent's failures.
We should grieve like David.
We should grieve when a failure happens.
We should grieve, uh, the mourning when someone
dies like that again.
We don't trust that we have to give our lives away to them.
No, but we should speak as well as we can about those,
even those who've wronged us,
be honorable towards those who
deserve honor, which the image of bearer of God
that everyone is deserves honor,
even despite their failures towards us.
Maybe that's what Jesus did.
This is what David modeled for us. David was a hi.
His heart was so in love with God
that he could love his enemy, even mourning
and grieving the loss, the death of this man
who had persecuted him.
Like that's a great king, isn't it?
That's a great king that he could be trusted like that.
Well, here's another aspect of David's qualifications.
This is chapters two and three.
Show us this again right after Saul died.
I mean he, it seemed like the pathway was open
for the, for David to take the throne.
But like the legend has said, not so fast my friend.
See, remember the chart? You're gonna see this
again throughout the series.
If you look all the way on the left,
David was immediately anointed king
but only anointed king of Judah, one
of the tribes of Israel.
And he made his home in he, which
it doesn't fit the rest of the story.
'cause you think Jerusalem and
all this stuff, yes, we'll get there.
But until then he's just, just in Hebrew,
a a little town in the south and he's king of one tribe.
Judah, Because Abner,
there's a name you're gonna need to remember, the commander
of Saul's army.
Abner had taken one of Saul's other sons
that didn't die in the battle ish.
Boche, that's his name.
I don't hear kids' name that anymore. I don't know why.
But uh, his name ish Boche, you can remember
that probably he Abner said, okay, no,
this son is the king of the rest of Israel.
David's king of Judah one tribe.
The 11 tribes are under this guy
and I'm his military commander, David Joab.
You guys are in Judah, that's fine.
But what we see setting up here is a civil war, right?
There's supposed to be one nation.
Now we've got this split happening with two people who claim
to be the king.
But notice what Abner was doing.
It was, it's a classic case of human
wisdom versus divine appointment.
God said, David's gonna be the king.
Abner said, no, this guy is, it's already setting up
to be a clash.
Well look at what chapter three verse one says,
just the second part of this.
This is the battle it's forming. The Civil War is beginning.
Watch what this verse says
to see the results of what happens.
It says there was a long war between the house of Saul,
the house of David, and David grew stronger
and stronger while the house
of Saul became weaker and weaker.
God who had promised this many, many years
before was shifting the kingdom to David.
It was happening even in a battle.
But here's what's interesting about this story.
It takes a little bit of a turn
because Abner actually defects from ish Bhe
and he comes over and he starts to follow David.
And all the 11 tribes that used to be under that side began
to slowly trickle over to follow David.
We'll see that over the next couple chapters.
And so Abner says, no, I'm
with David Now there was a problem though
because Joe Ab, who is David's primary military leader,
was not involved in those conversations.
So imagine this Joe AB is on the opposite side from Abner.
And then he comes home one day
and all of a sudden he hears that Abner's on their side.
Now watch what happens here.
This is chapter three verses 22 through 25.
This is what Joab thought of the whole situation.
Just then the servants of David arrived
with Joab from a raid, bringing much spoil with them.
But Abner was not with David at Hebron
for he'd sent him away and he'd gone in peace when Joab
and all the army that was with him came, it was told Joab,
Abner the son, Abner came to the king, he's let him go
and he's gone in peace.
And then Joab went to the king and said, what have you done?
Be old Abner came to you.
Why is it you sent him away so that he's gone?
You know, Abner, the Sonner came to deceive you
and to know you're going out and you're coming in
and to know all that you are doing.
He's like, dude, listen. Did you not? That's your enemy.
Abner's your enemy. What are you doing?
You're giving him a chance to see what we're doing
and how we're gonna battle his people.
Now lemme just give you a side note.
Abner had killed Joe Abs brother in the earlier battle.
So there was some serious animosity between these two guys,
even though they're on the opposite sides, there's even more
so that there's this personal piece of it as well.
And so Joab watch how he handles this.
Verse 26, when Joab came out from David's presence,
he sent messengers after Abner
and they brought him back from the cistern of Cyrah.
But David did not know about it.
And when Abner returned to Hebrew
and Joab took him aside into the midst of the gate to speak
with him privately and there he struck him in the stomach so
that he died for the blood of Asel, his brother.
And so here we have another test for David.
We have division in the nation,
we have this conflict amongst his leaders.
And now there's this murder which could have been
understood that David was the one
who manipulated this whole thing to work out,
that he had job go take out Abner.
It could have come back to David.
At the very least, it's one
of his generals murdering someone.
Like that's all really a big test for David's leadership.
How's he gonna lead through this crisis? Watch this.
Verse 28 afterward, when David heard
of it, he said, I and my kingdom are forever guiltless
before the Lord for the blood of Abner.
The son of no like he publicly
disavowed abner's.
He had, I have nothing to do with this.
Even watch this verse 29.
May it fall upon the head of Joab
and upon all his father's house, may the house
of Joab never be without.
Like he, he calls a curse down on Joab.
He's like, I didn't have anything to do with this.
Joab did it. And he is cursed
because of the vengeance he took on Abner.
Now look at verses 31 and 32, then David said to Joab
and to all the people who are with him, tear your clothes,
put on sackcloth and mourn
before Abner King David followed the beer,
the the funeral procession, they buried Abner at he
and the king lifted up his voice
and wept at the grave of Abner and all the people wept.
So again, just like with Saul, what's David doing?
He's publicly mourning for his enemy.
I mean remember Abner was on Saul's side.
He would've helped Saul try to take out David.
And now David is saying this enemy,
I'm mourning for his death.
And now verse 35,
then all the people came to persuade David
to eat bread while it was yet day.
But David swore saying, God do so to me
and more also if I taste bread
or anything else till the sun goes down.
That's just a sign of grief, lamenting publicly fasting
because of the death of Abner.
But I want you to watch what all that did.
So that was David's response to this whole crisis.
Watch what happens next, 36 and 37.
And all the people took notice of it
and it pleased them as everything that the king did,
pleased all the people.
So all the people in all Israel understood that day
that had not been the king's will to put to death.
Abner the son of Ner.
So you see what happened, David's
transparency, David's integrity.
Through the process, it won the people's hearts.
David led with integrity.
Like this is why God could trust David to be the king,
not Saul whose heart was far from God.
David's heart is close to God.
And he says here David, I'm gonna give you the kingship.
Why? Because here we see even through division, David led
through that with integrity.
All kinds of things could go haywire here,
divided people, divided leaders.
But David led with integrity
through division, through war, through blatant sin.
David was that. Now listen, what does integrity even mean?
Integrity is when your private life matches
your public testimony.
Like it's not your one way, that way
and one way here you're the same in every situation.
Is that true of you?
And I'm not just saying like when things are really good in
life, of course it's easy to be the same both ways.
But when things crumble in your life
and internally you're one way but externally
or a different way is your life marked by integrity?
And let's just, let's just play it out in real ways.
Think about how often we as Christians
say we should act in certain ways
and then the reality of our lives looks radically different.
And and I'm not saying that just from kind
of objective evidence, statistically this bears out.
Lemme just give you a couple examples.
We talk about sexual purity a lot,
yet pornography
and just messing around runs rampant,
not just through young people, through
older generations as well.
We declare that, that we
as Christians believe in the sacredness of marriage.
And yet dozens upon dozens of spouses
feel mistreated.
They're terrified and they're abused within churches.
We say we believe in caring for the poor, caring
for the outcast, being generous to those in need,
yet our money and our time flow to the lake house
or to more toys for ourselves.
And we could go on and on we
say, And yet we do.
And listen, here's the problem.
It's not just that we're disobeying God when our lives
don't come close to matching what we say.
The world sees all this as mere religious performance.
They don't see true faith.
They see a social club with a little bit
of morality sprinkled on top of it.
Is that what this is? Now we
say it's not, but
does it play out that way?
And so something needs to change in our lives, right?
Like something needs to change and
and we see David living with integrity
through the chaos of all that.
How did he get there? Well, I want you
to watch something real quick.
Go back to chapter two, verse one,
chapter two, verse one.
This is right after Saul died. He finds out about it.
Watch this Chapter two verse one.
After this, after Saul died, David inquired of the Lord,
shall I go up into any of the cities of Judah?
And the Lord said to him, go up.
And David said, okay, to which shall I go up?
And God said to he,
now we could skate over that really quickly.
But did you see the key phrase, David inquired
of the Lord?
That phrase is used at least six times in first
and second Samuel David inquired of the Lord
before he stepped into something.
David inquired of the Lord.
And that reveals something about David's heart, doesn't it?
It means his highest priority was knowing
and obeying God's will with integrity.
He trusted God. Your will is over my personal ambition.
I think I could do it this way,
but God, what do you want me to do?
I think I wanna go over here.
God, what do you want me to do?
And then any authority he walked into,
he received it from above.
He received it before he lived it out,
he responded in submission to the ultimate authority
and said, okay, God, what do you want?
I'm giving you my life.
Is that how you live your life
before making any decision,
before stepping forward in any way you
say, God, what do you want?
Like Jesus said it this way.
Do you pray God not my will, but your will be done?
Is that how we walk into life?
Are you thinking first
and foremost, God, your commands are my highest priority?
Nothing else. God, not my personal ambition, my preference,
I want your will be done.
Or are you more focused on personal ambition?
Are you more focused on saying, I'm gonna go about my way,
I'm gonna do it this way.
I'm gonna force my plan rather than wait on God's
plan and God's timing.
Listen, I can get there so fast.
I can go through my life as, as I trust my own intuition.
I trust my own history, my own knowledge.
I can go back and lean on everything rather than saying,
okay, God prayerfully God, what do you want me?
What? Let me find in your word.
How do you want me to handle this situation?
How do you want me to go through my life?
How would you say I handle this? All of that.
Is that the way you live your life?
Or are you just saying, God, I got this.
I'll see you on the other side.
And we wonder why we say this is what we believe,
yet we do this over here.
This is why. And
so integrity and integrity is
where you say something you believe and you do that.
It matches your public life.
Testimony matches your private life.
What's the environment that that grows in?
It's this attitude where you seek God's will above your own.
You submit to his leadership
and he in that process, he makes you more like Jesus.
If you've just woken up every morning and said, not my will,
but yours be done in that temptation on Friday night,
not my will but yours be done in that moment.
You have to make a decision of
where you're gonna spend your life.
Not my will but yours be done, right? That's the the choice.
Day by day moment by moment, not my will, but yours be done.
And as you do that in small ways,
God prepares you for the bigger things, just like he did
with David
so far here in first
and second Samuel, we've watched David
do all that pretty well.
He's been a good example, how to love our enemies.
How to live with an eternal mindset.
How to, how to live and lead with integrity.
He's been a good example.
Sadly, that won't be true for much longer.
You may remember Adam and Eve's story in the Garden of Eden.
Two chapters were great.
Chapter three, everything falls apart.
It doesn't take much time for David
to fall into similar traps that Saul
and many others did.
Which leads us back to the overall point of these books.
David is a good example of a man after God's own heart.
He's a great king, Israel's greatest king.
But hear this,
David is not the hero of this story.
He's merely a pointer
to the true hero.
The one who fulfilled what David could only
resemble Jesus Christ.
See David, Jesus fulfilled what David could only
bear some resemblance to he.
He looked a little bit like the Savior.
He lived a little bit like the Messiah.
He was in many ways a type of the Christ,
the Savior to come.
He teaches us a whole lot about the Messiah.
That's why this Messiah is called the Son of David, partly
because of how David exemplified it.
And of course through David's line, the Messiah came,
yet there was a greater king to come from David,
the perfect king, the one who fulfilled,
who did in full everything that David could only do.
In part who David only modeled,
who David only did imperfectly.
He was able to do it perfectly, fully and fulfill it all.
Just think about how Jesus is the greater David, right?
Listen, Jesus loved his enemies, not just
by grieving over them, but by actually dying for them.
Jesus sought his father's will perfectly, even in the Garden
of Eden, with the cross facing him the next day, Jesus said,
not my will, but yours be done.
Jesus led with complete transparency
and integrity every moment of his life.
Hebrews four 15, we do not have a high priest who's unable
to sympathize with our weaknesses,
but one who in every respect has been tempted as we are
yet without sin.
And because of that, through his death
and resurrection, he ended the ultimate division between God
and sinners, bringing lost humanity back
to himself, back home to the Father.
That's what Jesus did.
The chaos David led through Jesus led through ultimate chaos
and he brought his people back to himself.
This is the greater king.
This is the Promised King,
the one we worship here today.
All praise to that true king Jesus Christ.
Let's pray together.
Lord, this is your word. Thank you for showing us
who you are through it
and showing us a little bit about ourselves.
And so, God, I pray right now for us that
There may be somebody walking in here today who was looking
for a king, and they've been looking
for a king in this world, in their own self, over
and over and over.
And they've always been disappointed
because those kings will always fail us.
Or maybe they've been looking for the way that they could.
They could live it out themselves.
They could be their own king.
They could live it out perfectly enough to be able
to be surely brought into heaven someday.
But God, you've shown us and shown them they can't.
God, we need a savior king
and praise you, God, that you did it for us.
And so may we worship with that in mind.
May we respond to you with that in mind.
In Jesus' name, amen.
Part of that response will be the Lord's supper today.
So invite Chris, one of our elders to,
uh, lead us through that time.
Thank you John. We do get the honor
and the privilege of celebrating the
Lord's Supper together this morning.
And, uh, what a beautiful thing this is that we get
to do as a church.
Um, remembering Jesus and what he has accomplished,
and one for us, what he has won in the victory for himself.
Um, and then looking forward, um, to him returning and,
and, uh, finishing the work that he began, uh,
if you are helping with serving the elements of the Lord.
So I invite you to go ahead
and, uh, make your way to start serving those,
passing out the trays.
And as they are working on, uh,
passing out those elements this morning, scripture tells us
to, uh, make this a time
of reflection to search ourselves.
And one, it tells us to look if there's any, um, anything
that's keeping us any sin that's keeping us,
especially within the body, uh, from, from, uh,
being in perfect unity with one another, if there's anything
that's causing this, uh, harmony
to not exist in the body, to deal with that,
or if there's unrepentant sin in our hearts
to deal with that.
And as also this is something for believers, for disciples
of Jesus to do.
Um, if you are not yet a disciple of Jesus
and not a believer or part of his family, invite you
to just go ahead and pass those trays on
and take this time as we all consider together.
Look inside, make sure there's nothing
that's unrepented in ourselves as we take this together.
So this is something that we do
because Jesus commands us to,
and it's a good thing that he does
because it, it reminds us of what he instituted
with his disciples on the night that he was betrayed just
before going to the cross.
Two, one, unite them together, remind them that it's going
to get hard, it's going to be rough,
but these are the things that hold you together.
The fact that I am, I'm laying down my life for you
and purchasing you as my body.
So we get to do that together this morning,
but also forces us to not just look in or look to the past,
but to look up at Jesus
and recognize that he is sitting on the throne today
and he is sitting in victory over sin and death.
And it also causes us to look forward to his return
where he is coming back for his bride, his church,
and he's making all things new.
And so we get to celebrate that together as a church.
And then finally, it causes us to look
around at one another.
And oftentimes we spend this time praying, which we should
and looking inward, but also look around, look
around at everyone in this room that we are
Jesus's body, his church.
And this is a communal thing. We're eating a meal together.
And let's celebrate this together, realizing that all
of this is for the glory of Jesus.
So as you have your elements, we're gonna read
as Paul instructs us to do it in first Corinthians 11,
the reminder of why we do this together as his people.
Paul says, for our received from the Lord Jesus,
what I also deliver to you
that the Lord Jesus on the night when he was betrayed,
he took bread.
And when he had given thanks, he broke it
and said, this is my body, which is for you.
Do this in remembrance of me.
So let's take the bread together.
And he says in the same way, also, he took the cup
after supper saying,
this cup is the new covenant in my blood.
Do this as often as you drink it and remembrance of me.
So let's take the cup in remembrance of Jesus.
And finally it says, for as often as you eat this bread
and drink this cup, you proclaim
the Lord's death until he comes.
And so that's what we've done this morning.
We've proclaimed Jesus' death
and his resurrection, recognizing
that he's coming back for his people.
So let's pray together as we recognize this morning.
Jesus, thank you first
of all for saving us, for your sacrifice, for giving us
your body and pouring your blood for us.
Thank you for redeeming a people, for yourself,
for creating unity amongst people
that have no business being in unity with one another.
But we are unified by you, Jesus, and your spirit.
And thank you for the the glorious promise that we have
of your return to make all things new.
One day. God, we submit to you, we love you,
and we thank you this morning, it's in your naming prayer,
and invite you to stand with us as we continue
to worship our Jesus this morning.
Sing to our king, who
and all,
And to
To the greater king.
Jesus, the one that is deserving of all praise.
Um, we sing these phrases of day and night.
Night and day, let incense rise.
It's the praise that we are giving
to him because he deserves it.
So as repeat, repeat this phrase.
Give him your adoration day
and incense rise,
day and night, night
and David incense rise,
day and night,
rise day.
And
give him your praise for you.
Enter
you of it all
you.
You deserve the glory
I'm calling God
who made a shepherd boy courageous.
I'm calling on the God
I goth
my own
God.
My God, I
You God, my God.
I need you.
Rock, rock ofs.
I'm standing
on
you.
Hear your children
prayer.
God.
God, I you, God I need you
is our rock.
I'm standing on.
That's our solid foundation, church.
He is not situations working out. He is.
And so let's run to him today
and tomorrow till the day we see him face to face.
If we can pray for you in any way,
if you're feeling overwhelmed or strained, there'll be men
and women up here at the front, kind of along the sides.
Just come find some of us.
We'd love to pray for you if we can.
And so, God, thank you for today.
Thank you for your blessing. We pray
that you would be glorified and honored in our lives every
moment as we live for you our king.
In Jesus authority we pray. Amen. Amen. Love you. Church.
We are sent
Is All
Today.
I give you today.
Come on, praise.
Today is the name.
Oh,
today, a singing
today, a
today forever.
Holy praise. Yes, we praise.
Thank you Jesus
Forever,
to the
is a great city.
Yes, it's from the valley to the mountain,
the desert, to the ll,
the as Long
today
day.
Today is a day
I name I
is
today
singer soul.
Visit today. Today
darkness.
I watch the
Look at
God's
are.
Don't you know your father?
Heaven?
You know,
Welcome to Henderson Hills.
We are disciple makers, anchored in truth, compelled
by love, and desperately dependent on the Lord.
We are generous with what God has given us,
and we share life giving help with those around us.
Our mission is to equip one another to love Jesus.
And lip syn, we are glad you're here.
Well, good morning, church. How are we doing this morning?
We good? Oh, all right. All right. I'm, uh, I am Chris.
I get the privilege of serving as one of your elders, uh,
here at Henderson Hills.
So glad that you're with us this morning.
Uh, if you are new, this is, maybe this is your first time
or maybe you've come for the last couple weeks, uh,
but you haven't had a chance to really get plugged
in with anyone here yet.
What I would encourage you to do is
to not leave here without shaking at least one person's
hand, uh, introducing yourself.
Hopefully someone's already done that for you this morning.
And another really easy way to do that is out in the lobby,
there is a new here desk.
Uh, go out there after the service, uh,
meet someone out there at the new hair desk,
and they will get you plugged in with a little bit
of the life at the church here.
I'll help you introduce you to
what we're about here at Henderson Hills.
And if you have been coming here for maybe a few weeks
or a few months, and you are interested in diving a little
bit deeper into the life of Henderson Hills here, uh,
what I would encourage you
to do is next week we have a meaningful membership class
that is happening right after church.
So I'd encourage you to get signed up for that
and be a part of our meaningful membership, uh,
work workshop or class, uh,
to learn a little bit more about Henderson Hills,
who we are, what we believe, uh,
and then what we're about here is serving Jesus.
Uh, so be a part of that. And then finally, uh,
the last thing I want to announce this morning is if you are
looking for a place to serve here at Henderson Hills,
perhaps, uh, you have some musical ability.
You sing, you play an instrument,
or you're really interested in learning
and participating in how the, uh, the lights
and the audio visual, the cameras, all of
that happens here at Henderson Hills.
What I would encourage you to do is come
to a worship ministry interest lunch next week
as well, right after the service.
Uh, I think it's gonna be done in the offices.
Come to that, uh,
learn a bit about our worship ministry here
and how you can get involved there.
There's also some staff out in the lobby
afterwards if you want to just talk to them
and learn more about what that looks like here.
So finally, what I want us to do is to stand up
and let's spend a little bit of time greeting one another,
fellowshiping together.
And I'll ask you this question.
Should we include a banjo
or a harmonica in our worship ministry here?
Well, I, I hate to end the conversations early.
Um, but hopefully you can pick those back up
after the service, pick up where, where you were.
Uh, I'd encourage you all to go ahead
and make your way back to your seats.
We're going to, uh, begin our time of worship
together here singing, and we're singing a new
song here this morning.
Now, we haven't sung before,
but in this song that we're singing,
we ask the question over
and over again, who is like the Lord, who is like Jesus,
this, this God that we serve.
And to help us consider that a little bit this morning,
I'm gonna read from Psalm one 13.
I'm gonna start in verse four.
It's gonna talk about who this God is that we serve.
So lemme read that for us this morning.
Starting in verse four, says, the Lord is high
above all nations and his glory above the heavens.
Who is like the Lord our God, who is seated on high,
who looks far down on the heavens and the earth,
and hear this, he raises the poor from the dust,
and he lifts the needy from the ash heep to make them sit
with princes, with the princes of his people.
He gives the barren woman a home,
making her the joyous mother of children.
Praise the Lord.
So this morning, that's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna praise the Lord,
and we're gonna consider who God is, who this Jesus is,
and all the things that are unique about him.
And as we consider those things,
we're just gonna result in this joyous praise
of who Jesus is.
So let's sing this song together this morning.
In praise of Jesus,
There was creation.
Who illuminates the stars?
Who has said eter in the ocean?
Oh, there just
can, the
can dark.
Who can? The curse generations
Who
you are the one who king the Lord over everything.
Jesus. There is no Father Jesus.
There is no Father.
Your world will never change
because your name is here to say Jesus.
There is no
Lord.
Celebrate who? He's no one
Like him. Let's
praise him this morning.
Yes, in light of who God is,
we have a story to tell, right?
He has done Good work in our lives if we are his child.
So let's proclaim the good work
that he's done in our life today.
When I was lost alone, your
presence was where I found home.
You were there
every high, every
you never without hope.
You breathe
throne down your life
to rescue us.
News that we can.
I'm gonna
Sing about all the good things
that he has done in our lives.
These characteristics of are true about who he
Is. Let's sing this out.
You are good. And I've witnessed it.
You are strong, and I've witnessed it.
You are constant. I've witnessed it,
and I'm confident I'll see.
And you and I,
Amen.
God, you are worthy. God, you are constant.
You are never changing God.
Even when our circumstances look different, God,
you are always the same.
I thank you for your faithfulness.
God, I thank you for the things
that you've done in our lives
and the ways you are continuing to work.
God, may we never forget that you are above it all.
God, you reign above it all and you are worthy. Amen.
You may be seated.
Well, good morning, church.
It is great to gather together like this every week.
Uh, my name's John, one of the pastors here.
I get to preach most of the time.
If I haven't met you yet, I'd love
to meet you sometime soon.
So just come say hi. When you see me.
Today's a really special day.
We are kicking off a new sermon series,
and we're gonna walk through the book
of Second Samuel over the next couple months.
Last fall and spring, we walk
through the book of First Samuel.
And so that began the story.
Now we're going to kind of continue the story
through the book of Second Samuel.
Last week, Aaron, well reminded us that really the whole
story has been about God's people
abandoning God as their king.
Uh, that's really the whole genesis of the story, is
that they were searching instead of following God,
they were searching for an earthly king.
And that has not gone well for them. And so they did that.
That was really the premise of it was, who shall reign?
It really should be God. But the, the secondary question
with that was then, well, okay, if they're searching
for an earthly king, who's gonna be that king?
And then it was the process of figuring out
who God had promised this type of man to lead the country.
But they had to figure out who that was.
And so we showed this chart, maybe some
of you remember this throughout the whole of one Samuel,
and we tracked how that played out.
And so we saw the transition from judges to kings,
and then how the development happened
where the first king was Saul.
And he looked the part head
and shoulders above her handsome, right?
He's the guy. And he, he seemed like he would be the one,
but his heart was not close to God.
And so God had promised a man
after God's own heart to lead his people.
And that transition from Saul then to David, God,
anointed David to replace Saul.
Well, second Samuel, that was first Samuel.
Second Samuel is David's rise to the throne.
How he steps into that role, and then how he handles it
after he steps into that role.
We're gonna use another chart for second Samuel.
So you might take a picture of this now.
We'll have it up every week at some point, usually.
So, uh, you'll see this a couple times,
but it's gonna be the rise and fall of David.
Now, the idea is yes, we're gonna learn
that David was God's promised king for Israel.
He was the one. But
we'll also see that David was limited.
He was the promised king.
But limited in that role,
there's gonna be a rise to the throne.
Yes, there will be, uh, David's, uh, process
of becoming the greatest King Israel ever had.
But then there's also gonna be faults
of David along the way,
and the consequences that come from those faults.
See, David is not always the hero
that we make him out to be.
In fact, there's some pretty serious issues,
which really may.
It means something that we need
to set up right here at the beginning of the whole series.
This is something we won't forget, can't forget, is
that David is merely a pointer
to the true promised King.
He's the promised king that, that Israel needed.
But, but he's really just pointing us forward to the true
promised King whose name is Jesus.
That's really what the whole book is about.
So in one sense, we'll see second Samuel's,
like David's testimony, his successes, his failures,
his experiences of God's grace.
That's a great picture for us to learn from.
But it's also the main point how all of that
points us to the Lord.
And so don't forget that as we go through it.
That's why I want to begin just by praying
for this whole series that we're gonna set a tone for this.
We're gonna ask the Lord to bless it, give us his power
as we walk through this power, this passage of scripture.
So, Lord, thank you for the opportunity to study
through your word.
And, and we don't, we don't know.
We don't think this is merely Man's words.
This is your word. And we know that with that
Holy Spirit, you empower your word.
You highlight, you exalt your word.
And so God, as as we study it over the next couple months,
this you unique Book of two Samuel Lord, use it to teach us,
use it to change our hearts and,
and move us forward to be more like you.
As we look to the true promised king that we celebrate
and worship every week, help us guys.
It's gotta be your work. It's not mine.
Get us outta the way. Remove distractions that we can see
what you want us to see in Jesus name.
Amen. And so I invite you now to turn in your copy
of God's word to Second Samuel early in the Old Testament.
You just start from the beginning.
You start flipping back a little bit.
You'll find second Samuel, uh, put a bookmark there
or your, your little ribbon in your Bible,
because we'll be there every week as we walk
through this narrative, as you turn there.
It might seem like as we walk through this,
that we're taking really big chunks of scripture.
And and that's partly true because we'll take a two
or three chapters at a time sometimes.
And, and that can seem overwhelming.
But the reality is that's just narrative.
That's just the, the nature of this. You, you have a story.
You can't break it up into little sections
or you lose the point of the story.
So we have to take bigger sections to understand the point
that God was trying to reveal here.
So for example, today we're gonna look at chapters one
through three, three chapters of two Samuel,
because part of it recaps
what we already saw at the end of one Samuel.
And the rest of it sets up David to be the king
that we need.
It sets up David, not just as the king,
but also the kind of king that God wanted for his people.
Not a king who would seize power by violence
or manipulation, but one whose integrity would
shine really brightly.
That's what he was saying through these couple chapters.
God, this God's saying to us, this is the kind of man
that I want to be the king.
And we'll see that in David in these chapters.
How he responds to Saul's death. That's a big test for him.
But also the division we see among God's people.
There's a big test there.
And again, all of it will point us forward
to the true king Jesus.
And so let's look now Second Samuel chapter one.
Again, I can't read all three
chapters, we just don't have enough time for that.
But I'm gonna give you highlights, summary statements,
dive into critical pieces of it and,
and walk through the story so we're not missing anything.
And so what wrap, what happens right outta the gate here is,
is the parallel account of Saul's death.
The King of Israel has died.
One Samuel 31 was, was the actual story
of Saul dying in the battle scene.
Here. It's David's account.
And, and David's experience at the same parallel time.
'cause what was happening, a big battle
with the Philistines.
These people were trying to overtake Israel.
David's in a different part of the country, and Saul
and his son, Jonathan, who was David's best friend,
by the way, they were in the battle
and they ended up dying in the battle.
Well, here's what happens. One
of the servants from Saul's camp who was an amalekite,
which is one of the defeated enemies of God's people,
he comes to David
and says, Hey David, listen, I, I'm,
I'm telling you some news you need to know Saul's died.
'cause David didn't know there wasn't Snapchat
or Twitter or anything like that.
It was just like David needed to find some guy shows up
and says, Hey, Saul is dead.
Now here's the thing about this guy.
He wanted to impress David.
He was certain in his mind that David would love
to hear the fact that Saul, his, his enemy, had died.
And so this man walks in, says, Hey David,
listen, Saul's dead.
I got him. I killed him. Them.
Now that's different than what we read in one Samuel 31.
It's a dis, it's distinct from that
because what we read in that is that Saul was
so badly wounded that he had fell on his own sword
and died in the battle.
And so this man walks in this am Malachi
and says, Hey, I killed him.
He's lying in order to curry favor
with the new king.
Maybe he'll give me a a position in his new
kingdom or something like that.
We don't know. But he's clearly lying to impress the king.
Well, watch how David responded to the news.
This man came and said, Hey, I got Saul. He's dead.
I did it. Aren't you proud?
Watch David's response verses 11 and 12 here in chapter one.
Then David took hold of his clothes and tore them.
That's a sign of grief.
And so did all the men who were with him.
And they mourned and wept and fasted until evening for Saul
and for Jonathan, his son, and for the people of the Lord
and for the house of Israel
because they had fallen by the sword.
Now, don't forget who Saul was.
Saul was the man who had multiple times tried to kill David.
He'd hunted him like a wild animal.
He had kept him on the run for 10 years. This was the man.
Saul was the man that we see.
David's heart show up.
Saul was the man that David was
grieving for his loss.
Instead of hatred, there was grief.
Instead of rejoicing over his enemy's death,
there was mourning.
David grieved the loss of God's anointed king that Saul was.
He even wrote a song of lament.
David wrote most of the Psalms, you can go through
and find his name on a lot of those.
He wrote a song of lament to be sung
by God's people over the loss of Saul
and Jonathan, we find it here in chapter one,
verses 19 through 27.
You can read the whole thing. I'm just gonna read
a couple pieces to show you.
It says verse 19, your glory,
Israel is slain on your high places.
How the mighty have fallen.
Verse 23, Saul and Jonathan, beloved
and lovely in life and death.
They were not divided. They were swifter than eagles,
stronger than lions.
He's upholding them. Verse 27, how the mighty have fallen
and the weapons of war perished.
So he wrote a song, uh, of grief for the nation to sing.
Not only that, watch how he responded to the amalekite man
who came and told him about Saul's death.
Look at verses 14 through 16.
David said to him, how is it you were not afraid
to put out your hand to destroy the Lord's anointed?
Then David called one of the young men
and said, go execute him.
And he struck him down so that he died.
And David said to the Amalekite, man,
your blood be on your head
for your own mouth has testified against you saying,
I have killed the Lord's anointed.
He had the man who claimed to have killed Saul.
He had him executed right like
this man, this Amalekite man should have recognized the
sanctity of God's anointed king.
He should have been terrified to touch him
because remember, that's what David did when David was
fleeing from Saul had multiple chances
to take Saul out instead of Saul trying to kill him.
He didn't. He said, no, no,
I'm not gonna touch the Lord's anointed.
He repeated that multiple times.
I'm not touching the Lord's anointed.
I'm not going to gain the throne improperly.
God promised it to me. I'm not gonna do it myself.
I'm going to allow God to do it.
This Amalekite man said a whole different mindset.
He's like, I'm gonna manipulate this whole
situation to my ends.
And what happened? He paid the ultimate price.
So here's the point. David revealed his heart
in his response to Saul's death.
That's what we see here.
David revealed his passionate love for God,
a man after God's own heart.
David revealed that here by the way.
He responded to his enemy, Saul dying.
'cause he could have. Think about it.
He could have rejoiced that. Saul's gone.
My opponent is gone. The pathway to the throne is clear.
Now I got this. I'm king. Now it's clear.
But he doesn't do that.
Which leads us to a question for us today.
Is that how you love your enemies?
Like do you grieve when your enemy suffers?
If your opponent or the antagonist in your life dies?
Do you mourn for their death?
Or are you more apt to throw a party
like, man, they deserved it.
They got what they deserve. Finally,
and listen, we saw this as we studied Romans 12 this summer,
one of the most challenging realignment statements in
Romans 12 verses 19 and 20.
Beloved never avenge yourselves,
but leave it to the wrath of God.
For it is written, vengeance is mine,
I will repay, says the Lord.
To the contrary, if your enemy is hungry, feed him.
If he's thirsty, giving something to drink for, by so doing,
you will heap burning coals on his head.
It doesn't say if he's hungry, laugh at him.
If he's thirsty, keep pushing him further away.
No, it says you provide,
you love them again.
Remember, David had multiple opportunities
to take out his enemy to kill Saul, but he didn't do it
'cause he trusted that God's justice is perfect.
Our revenge is never perfect.
We don't know the situation fully.
We will not do it rightly,
and we'll be guilty on the other side of it.
So David trusted God to deal with the situation.
And you know what? It ended up actually way better
for David than if he had taken Saul out
some other way, some other time.
It ended up better for David
'cause no one could accuse David of anything.
At this point. He's in a
whole different part of the country.
He had no knowledge of it even happening.
And now David is the king.
His hands were clean. Why?
Because of Romans 12, that mentality.
He said, I'm gonna overcome evil with good.
I'm not gonna, like Martin Luther King Jr.
Said, I'm not gonna overcome evil
with evil 'cause that just multiplies evil.
I'm gonna overcome evil with good.
And we see the result. And
so let's just play this out for us.
If that attitude is true of us, if that's commanded of us,
don't you think that should mean our lives look pretty
different than the way of the world,
even than what they commonly do.
It means things should be very different in
how we speak about those who oppose us, those
who are considered enemies, those who are antagonizing us.
We should speak differently about them.
Our social media usage should be very different in the way
we speak about people.
That way our bumper stickers on our car should not be just
like everybody else's in the world.
If this is the mentality, if Jesus said to love your enemies
and to pray for those who persecute you, we should refuse
to rejoice when someone on the other side
of the aisle suffers.
We should be radically different in the way we treat
those who oppose us.
Now, I'm not saying we trust those people,
but I am saying we ought to speak as well as we can of them.
Even if they've heard us, we should try to honor
what we can in that image bearer of God like we are.
And yes, we don't give everything away to them,
but despite their failures toward us,
if Jesus looked at his enemies
and said, father, forgive them, we can do the same.
It's what David models so well.
His heart was so in love with God
that he could love his enemy, by grieving his enemy's death,
by honoring him through a song.
This man who persecuted him.
I mean, that's the kind of king that God wanted, right?
It's a good king. So that's one aspect
of his qualifications.
Here's another. In the chapters two
and three, we start to see
some things show up in David again that adds
to the qualifications again.
When Saul died, it seemed like now there's a clear path
to the throne like David, man, it's yours now.
Everything is good except for like the, uh,
legend once said, not so fast my friend.
We're gonna throw the chart back up there
and you'll see it on the left.
David was immediately anointed king of Judah,
which was only one of the 12 tribes of Israel.
And then you see that he moved to Hebron,
which is a small town in the south.
It's not Jerusalem, which is eventually going to be the,
the the capital that we will find out, of course.
But he's in Hebron. He's down in the middle of nowhere.
King of just one of the 12 tribes.
Because here's what happened.
Abner, who was the commander of Saul's army,
Abner, took one of Saul's other sons
who didn't die in the battle.
His name was ish Boche,
which is not on the top 10 baby names.
I don't know why, but ish Boche,
He took that son and said, you're the king.
Your dad was Saul, you're the king of these tribes.
All of Israel. 11.
Well, David's over here, king of one tribe, Judah,
which is really small too.
And him and Joe Ab, his military commander,
they're over here doing this and Israel chef
and Abner over here doing this.
It, it starts to smell like civil war, doesn't it?
And, and things are starting to heat up a little bit here
that, that Abner didn't like David.
And so he's like, I'm gonna make Raeth the king
and this is what's gonna look now.
Well, it was clearly a case of human, human intuition,
human wisdom versus divine appointment.
David, anointed by God as the king Abner says,
no, no, no ish, which that's gonna be the king.
Well watch what happens. Look at chapter three.
Skip ahead a little bit to chapter three verse one.
We're gonna see the results of that as we go skipping a lot
of the battles that happened.
But watch this verse one of chapter three.
There was a long war between the house
of Saul and the house of David.
And David grew stronger
and stronger while the house of Saul became weaker
and weaker Even
through a battle, God was fulfilling his promise to David
to shift the kingdom to David.
It was happening. God was bringing about the fulfillment
of his promise.
But here's what's interesting about how this played out.
What happened next is that Abner who was with the 11 tribes
and with the king, he anointed, he actually defects
and changes his mind
because of something the Israel did to him.
He changed his mind and said, no, I'm following David now.
He defects and comes over to follow David
and all the 11 tribes begin to trickle alongside with him.
We'll see that over the next couple chapters.
But there was a problem. Abner was the enemy.
Military commander, David's commander Joe Joab was not
involved in those conversations.
Joab has no idea this is happening.
He's out doing the work
and he comes home, watch what he thought was happening.
This is verses 22 through 25
of chapter three, Starting verse 22.
Just then the service of David arrived
with Joab from a raid, bringing much spoil with them.
But Abner was not with David at Hebrew.
And he'd sent him away. He'd gone in peace when Joab
and all the army with him came, it was told Joab, Abner,
the son of Ner came to the king.
He's let him go. He's gone in peace.
And then Joab went to the king and said, what have you done?
The old Abner came to you.
Why is it that you sent him away so that he's gone?
You know, Abner, the son of Ner came to deceive you
and to know you're going out.
You're coming in and to know all that you are doing.
Now here's a little side note, why would Abner not?
Well Joe Ab not trust Abner, partly
'cause he was on the other side, but also
Abner had killed Joe Abs brother in a battle earlier.
So there was already personal
animosity between the two of them.
And Joe was like, dude, listen, he, David, he's coming
to try to figure out our plans.
He's deceiving. You don't trust him.
Well watch how Joab handled this situation.
Verses 26
and 27, When Joab came out from God's,
from David's presence.
He sent messengers after Abner
and they brought him back from the cistern of Sarah.
But David did not know about this.
And When Abner returned to Hebrew
and Joab took him aside in the midst of the gate to speak
with him privately, and there he struck him in the stomach
so that he died for the blood of Asel, his brother.
This is a test for David, isn't it?
You've got division among the people, you've got
conflict among his leaders.
It's a test of David as the new king.
Plus you have not only the divisions, you have this murder.
Now that it could have come back on David,
that he manipulated the enemy's death.
He brought Abner in here, he deceived him
and then sent Joe AB to go finish the job.
Like, no, he, he could have been read that way.
If it's not that at,
at the very least it's you got a general murdering another
general, like that's not so it's a problem.
It's a test. How was David gonna lead through the crisis?
Watch verse 28.
Afterward, when David heard of it, he said, I
and my kingdom are forever guiltless
before the Lord for the blood of Abner, the son of Ner.
Like he publicly disavowed anything, any involvement.
He didn't have anything to do with this.
Even the next verse, he calls down a curse on Joab
because Joab took vengeance he shouldn't have.
David says, I didn't do it. Joab did it and he was wrong.
Now verses 31 and 32, watch.
And then David said to Joab
and to all the people who were with him, tear your clothes
and put on sackcloth and mourn before Abner
and King David followed the beer.
That's the the coffin.
They buried Abner at Hebron and the king lifted up his voice
and wept at the grave of Abner and all the people wept.
This sounds familiar, doesn't it?
It's what he did with Saul enemy number one. Saul.
David grieved him.
Abner was on the other side with Saul
and he grieved abner's loss publicly.
And Now verse 35.
And then all the people came to persuade David
to eat bread while it was yet day.
But David swore saying, God do so to me
and more also if I taste bread
or anything else, till the sun goes down.
That's just signs of grief.
He's lamenting fasting publicly saying,
you should be grieving the loss of Abner two.
So he's again, showing his heart.
But watch what all that did.
Here's why I went through this watch
what happens next verses 36 and 37,
and all the people took notice of it
and it pleased them as everything
that the king did, pleased all the people.
So all the people of and all Israel understood that day.
It had not been the king's will to put to death.
Abner, the son of Ner.
Like you see what happened, David, in his transparent
integrity filled leadership,
he won the hearts of the people.
Like, no, no, David didn't do that. That was Joab.
We love David. We trust David. Watch how he's responded.
It won the people's hearts.
You see why God could trust David
with the kingship of his people.
His heart was close to God, he was wanting
to do all the right things in every situation.
David led through division, he led
with integrity like that.
That's the point here. Even through division, the chaos
murders and, and people divided and,
and tribes splitting up like all of this.
David was like, I, I have integrity
and I'm going to lead with it through all of that.
Now, what is integrity? Basic answer,
integrity is when your private life matches
your public testimony, the way you think and live
and act inside yourself matches the way
that you act publicly.
You're the same in every situation. Is that true of you?
And and I'm not just saying like when things are really
good, you know, you can do
that when things are good in your life,
of course you can act the same way with everybody.
It's not, that's not a problem.
But when things fall apart, crumble, it begins
to really squeeze out what's
actually in the sponge of your heart.
Are you the same in every situation? That's integrity.
And I man, this, this was hard to, this part was hard
for me this week to write,
but let, let's just think about how we as Christians
don't do this very well.
Think about how often what we say
we believe and how we should live
doesn't in any way match the way we actually live.
And I don't just say that to, to say, well,
I think objectively kind of, you know, it's,
it's a bit of here and there.
I see it happen from time to time.
No, statistically this bears out that we
as Christians say, we believe and do certain things,
but we actually don't.
Lemme give you a couple examples.
We talk about sexual purity a lot, yet pornography
and just messing around runs rampant,
not just in younger people, in every generation,
we declare the, the sacredness that we as Christians,
marriage is sacred and yet hundreds upon hundreds
of spouses are abused and mistreated
and are terrified to go home within churches.
We, we say we believe in caring for the poor, caring
for the outcast in providing generously to people in need,
yet our money and our time flow to the lake house
or to more toys for ourselves.
We say we believe, we say we treasure and cherish,
and yet our lives look so far from it.
And we could go on and on. There's list after list.
But listen, when our lives don't come close to matching
what we say, the world looks at this
and just sees it as religious performance.
They don't see true faith.
What they see is a social club with a little bit
of morality sprinkled on top of it.
And so something needs to change in our lives, right?
Like, is that all this is, is this just a social club
that we have some Jesus language on top?
Is that all? Is that all this is something needs
to change in our lives?
How do we get to that level of integrity
where we're the same person?
Every situation, every situation of life,
we're gonna look the same externally, internally,
regardless of how our life's going.
How can we get there? How did David get there?
Go back quickly to chapter two verse one.
Just quickly look at this Chapter two verse one.
This was right after Saul died,
the crisis moment of his life.
He could decide to go whichever way he wanted.
Watch this verse one
after this, David inquired of the Lord,
shall I go up into the any of the cities of Judah?
The Lord said to him, go up. Okay?
David said, all right, to which shall I go up?
And he said to Hebrew, did you see what that phrase was?
David inquired of the Lord.
That phrase appears at least six times in first
and second Samuel I, as he is deciding where
to go, deciding what to do.
Should I do this? Should I, how could I talk this way?
David inquired to the Lord.
David inquired to the Lord
that's revealing something about his heart, right?
It means David's highest priority was knowing God's will
and obeying God's will.
David, I God's, God's saying, David is saying,
God, I want to follow you.
I want to know your will. I wanna be obedient to you.
He, he had integrity
and he was saying, God, I trust your will over my ambition.
I want nothing else but your will.
Any authority he received came from his
submission to the ultimate authority.
It wasn't him claiming it, it was him receiving it
and he lived it out with integrity.
Is that how you live your life?
Have you said to your heavenly Father, not my will,
but your will be done in every
situation, every moment.
Your highest priority is God, I wanna obey you.
Your commands, your leadership,
everything in my life is all yours.
Or are you more focused on your personal ambition,
your personal preferences, your way of doing things?
Are you trying to force through your plan instead of waiting
for God's timing?
Are you going about your life?
And man, this is really easy for me to do.
Are you going through your life saying, okay,
I've got all this intuition, I've got all this knowledge,
I've got all this history.
I know how to live my life. I know where I'm going.
I don't need you. God, none of us would ever say
that, but we live it.
Instead of humbly coming to prayerfully, coming
to God's Word and saying, God, what do you want?
Like God, what's your will?
Clearly commands are his will.
But then he's like, he,
he's not maybe gonna write it on the sky where you should go
to college or where you should do this
or that, or who are you gonna marry?
Whatever it is like He, but, but you should filter
it through the lens.
God, show me God, tell me whichever way
and trust he's gonna lead your pathway as you go.
Is that the way you live your life?
Every moment you wake up of the day and,
and every moment of the day you say, God, not my will,
but your will be done on Friday night.
When that temptation comes, God,
not my will, your will be done.
When you face that crisis moment in your family, God,
not my will, your will be done at work
and you're tempted to do a little bit of cutting corners,
God, not my will, but your will be done.
Is that how you live your life?
That's the environment integrity grows in.
That's when you submit to the, the will of the Father
and you say, God, I'm getting out of the way.
It's yours. I'm following you.
He makes you more Christ-like
'cause you obey him, you follow him.
And that's how he grows the character in you
that looks more like Jesus in the small things
as he prepares you for something that may be bigger later
and so far in first and second Samuel.
But we've seen David do that pretty well.
But sadly that won't last very long.
You may remember the story in Genesis of the Garden of Eden
and Adam and Eve, like it was really good for two chapters.
And then chapter three, it all tanks
and everything goes south.
And, and we'll see David
fall into some of the same traps that Saul
and others did as the king,
which again leads us to the overall point of these books.
Yes, David's a great example.
He's a man after God's own heart.
He's Israel's greatest king.
But hear me, David is not the hero of this story.
He's merely a pointer to the true hero.
The one who fulfilled all that David could merely
resemble Jesus Christ.
Jesus fulfilled
what David could only bear some resemblance to
now we're gonna see David.
Yes, he appeared to be a savior in many ways.
He re he brought the nation together.
He was a savior of his people.
He was kind of messiah like kind of Christ-like in a way.
He was a type. He taught us a lot about the Messiah to come.
But he is not the savior.
There's a true greater king to come after David.
And he's the one that we stand today
and we worship the perfect king who did everything in full
that David could only do in part who fulfilled it all.
Everything David did imperfectly.
Jesus did perfectly just listen to how he did this,
how Jesus is the greater David.
He loved his enemies, not just by grieving for them,
but by dying for them.
Jesus sought the father's will perfectly, even in the garden
of Gethsemane when he's facing the, the horror of the cross,
the very next day he said,
not my will, but your will be done.
He always led with complete transparency and integrity.
Hebrews four 15, we do not have a high priest who's unable
to sympathize with our weaknesses,
but one who in every respect has been tempted as we are
yet without sin.
That's our king. Perfect.
And because of that perfection,
because of that obedience through his death
and resurrection, he has ended the ultimate division
between God
and humanity, by bringing sinners back home
to God the Father, the civil war
that David faced has no candle to hold
to the desperate dependence we have on God
to take sinners home with him only through his work.
That is our king. That's who this is pointing us to.
And all praise should go to that true king Jesus Christ.
Let's pray. God, thank you so much for your grace
and mercy, your word pointing us to those truths.
And I pray, God, that, that we would recognize
and see you as the true king.
Learn from what we can with David,
but point to you, look to you, worship you.
But I know there's some of us walked in this room today,
and we've spent most of our lives looking for a king
In this world, somebody to satisfy, somebody
to fulfill somebody, to protect
something, to do all of that.
And they are disappointed and exhausted in that search.
Some have walked in here looking for themself
to be the king, to be able to live it out perfectly,
to be this one that, that I just described.
And they're recognizing that they can't do that.
They never could. And so God,
what you're just showing us always is that we need
to save your king
and praise the Father that you provided.
God the Son, took on flesh to do all of this
so that we could be saved, which means you're worthy.
So God, draw us to yourself in that, help us see you rightly
and respond to you rightly in Jesus' name.
Amen. Part of
that response today involves the Lord's supper as a reminder
of what that savior king has done for us.
So invite El uh, one of our elders, Chris,
come lead us through that.
Thank you John, for that message of, um,
a reminder of our call to integrity,
but also the reminder that Jesus is the one
that's the perfect example of all of thats the reason
that we are here today.
We have this fellowship together as disciples,
as his believers, as his followers, And
that's why we serve the Lord's Supper.
So if you are, um, if you're helping to serve the, the,
the elements this morning, will you go ahead
and make your way and begin in passing out those trays?
I do wanna remind us though that this is something
that we do as, as, uh, god's, as Jesus's disciples,
as unified body.
And so there are a couple of instances
where we shouldn't take this, um,
this supper, this meal together.
And if you are not a disciple of Jesus yet, our hope is
that you are and you become part of this body.
Um, but we would ask you to go ahead
and just pass those trays on, um, as this is something
that Jesus has commanded for his church to do.
And if you have any unrepentant sin
or grievances, especially within the body that are, um,
not dealt with, I would also encourage you to pass that on.
And, and until we've, uh, restored unity
and harmony within the body,
and we take this meal together rightly, uh,
to honor the unity that Jesus has created in the body,
and as we take this meal together, we're reminded
of why Jesus commands us to do this.
And it's, it's such a good thing that Jesus does command us
to take this meal together
because it's a reminder of several things.
One, it's a reminder how Jesus has created a people
He's brought out like as in an exodus, a people for himself.
And the way he did is by dying on a cross,
shedding his own blood, breaking his own body so
that we can be redeemed.
And so it's a reminder of that.
It's also a reminder of the unity he's created in the body
that we share together.
But it's also a reminder of
how Jesus is victorious reigning on the throne right now.
So what I'm going to do is, uh,
I'm gonna encourage us to look a few different directions,
look in the past or look inwardly first
to see if this is something we should
be participating in this morning.
Look to the past. Remember what Jesus has done for us
to create this church.
Look upward to recognize Jesus on the throne
reigning even today.
And then look forward to see what he has promised to redeem
fully people for himself and make all things new.
And that's what we celebrate this morning.
So as you receive the elements,
there'll be two cups stacked on top of each other,
the bread and, and the drink.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna read through these instructions
that Paul gives us for taking of this supper.
He says in one Corinthians 11, Paul says,
for I received from the Lord, what I also deliver to you
that the Lord Jesus on the night when he was
betrayed, he took bread.
And when he had given thanks, he broke it
and said, this is my body, which is for you.
Do this in remembrance of me.
So let's do that as we remember Jesus this morning.
And it says in the same way also, he took the cup
after supper saying, this cup
is the new covenant in my blood.
Do this as often as you drink it in remembrance of me.
So let's drink the cup together.
And then the way he he finishes the says is he says,
for us often as you eat this bread
and drink the cup, you proclaim the Lord's
death until he comes.
And so church, that's what we've just done today
by taking these simple elements, this cracker
and this juice we've proclaimed
in a way we can't even fathom Jesus's death
and what that has accomplished.
And we look around this room
and recognize all of this belongs to Jesus, all of us.
It's for him and for his glory.
And then we look to the future
and we proclaim not just his death, but his resurrection
and the fact that he's coming back.
And so this is something we do in celebration
and remembrance, yes.
But also in celebration of the victory
that Jesus has won for himself.
So let's celebrate that today. Church, let me pray for us.
Father, we are so thankful.
Jesus, we are so thankful for you
and for how you have won this victory.
How you have made us a people unified in your body,
purchased by your blood.
God, remind us this morning just how great
of a king we have in Jesus
and make us more into the image of Him as we,
as we spur one another on.
Lord, we love you. It's your name. Amen.
So will you stand with us as we respond to that good news
and worshiping our king Jesus together
And all the saints,
throne and all
elders
of it,
you all,
You the
All this greater king Jesus,
he does deserve the glory this morning from his people.
So as he sing these lines, I say day and night.
Night and day, let incense rise.
It's the praise of his people rising up to him, giving him
what he is worthy of.
So as this church just sing this, lift your praise to him,
your hearts, your minds up to him
worthy of it.
You the
For from you are all things.
And until you're all things who you deserve
glory from.
You, Thomas,
for from you are all things.
Let's call out to our God This morning
I'm calling God
who made a
calling calling on the God
of who?
May the shepherd boy
Courageous.
I may not face,
but I've got my own shy.
Oh God, my God I need
You.
Oh God, my God,
I need you now.
I need you
God.
I need God
And your children.
You hear your children now you,
oh God, my God I need you.
Oh God, my God I need you.
How I need you
of I'm standing on your faith,
on your faithfulness.
We praise God for that faithfulness. Amen. Amen. Yep.
That is, that is, he is the rock.
Not this not situations being right. He is the rock.
His faithfulness to us is what we build our lives on.
And so you can, maybe you're struggling with that right now.
Don't know the answers, don't know what's coming,
what's next, how to handle situations.
If we can pray for you.
There's many women right here at the front
after every service, we'd love to pray for you
and just help kind of take that need to the throne of grace,
to find mercy and grace in our time of need.
We do need him. It's okay to admit that it's,
it's a safe place to admit
that you don't have it all together.
Uh, 'cause he does praise God for that. Thank you Lord.
Thank you for your grace and mercy to us today.
Um, send us with your power to live a life
of integrity that looks so different
because you've transformed us.
Holy Spirit, make that happen.
Help us one baby, step forward today.
Another one tomorrow, another one the next day
until we see you face to face.
Thank you God. In Jesus' name we pray. Amen. Amen.
Love you church. We are sent.
I'm
the.